[Music]
e-everybody welcome to planet Costa
College this is just a quick video about
pops and by that I don't mean the basics
part mechanic in game and how to use it
nor do I mean making part of layouts in
Plex as a whole I'm talking about
creating these fluid smooth plazas and
path areas in parks plazas that are in
square and paths that are actually wide
and very heavily detailed and set you up
in this sort of adventurous part instead
of just a simple small trail and to be
quite honest I actually want to look at
if you realize parks first to kind of
explain what I mean by this for those of
you aren't really too sure how I'm
actually all about right now because one
of the most important things that I
would say you should keep in mind while
building parts in planet coaster is to
not do it the way that the path system
wants you to do it
the path system and planet coaster is
very much created around creating these
trails sort of these small paths that go
through the park whereas in real life
you very often see that path systems
exist as these very large wide-open
spaces in fact planet coaster kind of
creates this mentality of paths are
going through your park as the places
that people can actually walk on but in
reality paths are very often just
everywhere like path is the default
state of a theme park and anything that
isn't part is creating these areas
between the pond and ridges like trees
planters buildings rides and roller
coasters and this is the mentality that
I really want to get around in this game
and what I think is very important if
you want to get up fluid smooth
realistic park layouts and I'll
basically be talking about how you want
to achieve this in game and a couple of
examples that I think can show this
pretty well
this one is see fully in Denmark it's a
super small park and it's definitely not
your standard fare in that sense but
even then you can see that a lot of
wide-open spaces are created with these
paths and the only thing that that isn't
path are these
is where there are planters in between
the paths over where there are rides or
buildings sure there are some areas of
course reserved for nature and there are
some trails as well but especially
alongside the most important buildings
and all of the rides in this area it's
just wide very smoothly curving plazas
and the same goes for an American park
like a quintessential American park like
Cedar Point's which isn't known for its
heavy theming it's really just about the
rollercoasters but even still the park
has very wide paths and especially if
you go to the entrance area you'll see
that pasture everywhere except for those
places which are just civilians or
buildings or rides and I think you can
definitely tell this in all of the
Disney parks as well if you look at
Epcot for instance which is very well
known for its landscaping it still has
those Whitely curving paths which are in
just small trails in the roller coaster
tycoon in one sense but are really just
wider open spaces with these planters
in-between and that is the kind of
layouts that I would like to move to
implanted coaster as well now of course
a very quick disclaimer this isn't
something you have to do there are
definitely some parks just around small
asphalt paths and this is definitely not
how you should be doing all of your
parts it's perfectly fine to have like
some small shortcuts or small little
pathways going around the park but
especially in some of your larger areas
where you're going to have more people
where you can have more rides more
roller coasters or if you're going for a
very blend or compact Park look you
really want to set up those parts in a
very wide smooth way so how do we
achieve this well I want to very quickly
share some tips in planet coaster itself
and kind of show you with very quick
example how I usually do this kind of
stuff and at the end of the video I'll
go into a real-life example in qawalli
Beach or that's not real life anyway
there are a few keys that are most
important to this the first being set
which is absolutely important and
necessary when it comes to create
smooth splits I guess between pots
creating smooth junctions and there's
also the control key which is really
important for having not all the parts
snap to each other so we got a bit more
freedom as to where all of your paths go
and then there is a trick which I need
to be super thankful for to free the
bear on shyguys world forum there were a
few other people as well who found this
trick out the tree the bear was the
person who posted a tutorial on shyguys
world on how to smooth out crosses and
smooth out any Junction really implanted
coaster and this basically showed the
way in which you can smooth out places
and Junction net and this is probably
the biggest game-changer recently in
terms of part styles and planet coasts
and that's something that I'll talk
about as well so without further ado
let's get into a quick example okay so I
want to create a sort of curved small
Plaza with a ride and a few buildings
next to it so what I'm going to start
out with is create one half of the plaza
I have no idea what all of these pigeons
are doing at the moment but just great
one half just kind of smoothly curved
then oh it's not really too afraid of
making this a very sort of rough sketch
of what it's going to look like because
once you create all the junctions
between the paths you'll see eventually
that these paths are going to look
pretty different that looks good like
the first part of the pot now for the
second part I'm going to try to make
this a little bit longer and while I
hold the Zed key I want to connect a
part over here and that should more or
less already create the basis of my
plaza here now you'll notice that we end
up with this weird little like well it's
pretty big actually this weird large
gross open area and you can very very
easily tell that these are two separate
paths and this is not actually a plaza
or anything in the middle now this is
where the ctrl key and especially the
smoothing out of junctions is going to
come into handy and before I talk about
that too much actually when I very
actually recreate the tutorial that we
the bear posted basically what he showed
off is the following and I'll turn off
angle snaps just to get this straight
once you have some job some junctions
you can actually smooth out the points
between these junctions by placing a
part in the middle trying to get this as
straight as I can there we go and then
just removing that part and as you can
see it actually smooths out the junction
now this was the original tutorial but
you can actually even go further than
this and start adding more of these
parts alongside the slide and you'll see
that planet coaster starts gradually
just filling out these areas and you can
eventually just make a very large curve
splatters that way which is amazing and
that's the way in which you can actually
kind of fill up the space between this
as well so basically what I want to do
here is I want to get rid of some of
these spaces that make this very
obviously look like two separate parts
and not like an actual Plaza so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to make the
width a little bit lower and see if I
can actually get in here that might
actually be a bit of an issue here
yeah I have an opening there we go and
let's see if we can actually get one in
between here as you can sell you might
want to make the junctions a little bit
less sharp because that makes it easy to
put things in the middle but we got it
anyway and now we've got that smoothed
out and it looks a little bit more neat
now but obviously this is still looking
like two separate paths so what I want
to start doing is there is no way to
fill in this entire area as much as I
would love to it's simply impossible but
what we can do is kind of shape the
parts around so that we have these
planter areas very similar to how you
saw in Cedar Point's and in Tivoli and
of course in which we can put some
decorations and some foliage that make
the entire area look like a smooth plaza
while at the same time also providing a
bit of scenery around it
I think an extra-wide path instead might
actually work quite well and I'm user
control and that kind you've got a bit
of a curve in here make that a bit more
interesting to look at and at this point
you can very easily still tell that this
is one extra part in the middle of two
different paths but that's why we start
adding some paths in the middle here and
kind of use that flower trick to smooth
stuff out now this is really a bit of a
trial and error process because it is
still pretty glitchy as you can tell and
especially in some of these very tight
corners it can be very difficult and
sometimes even flat-out stops working
that's actually an important thing to
highlight as you can see all of the
areas which we start smoothing how it's
turned into one big path piece and this
isn't too much of an issue like if you
remove them you lose a lot of parts but
you can just instantly redo that the
only thing to keep in mind here is that
you can't actually smooth out on the
borders of these enormous path pieces I
have no idea why this is this entire way
of making use of the mechanic is pretty
glitchy in itself but there is no way to
do it so if we take this corner for
instance it's on the corner of different
big path pieces and there's just no way
of smoothing that part out so that's
something you're going to have to keep
in mind trying to get sort of the shape
that I'm looking for here on this pause
here which isn't quite working kind of
annoying let's see if we can still do
anything there actually I think that
might work there we go
that's pretty much the shape that I'm
looking for and you can imagine that you
know this is just one small Plaza and
I'll dress that up in a little bit but
if this were in the middle of the park
you kind of want to follow the same
theme throughout the entire area and to
the parts that it's connecting to as
well so imagine there would be a piece
played through some different parks or a
different part of the park or a roller
coaster down here that you still want to
kind of smooth that out in a very
similar sense try and get it as smoothly
connected to have it very smoothly flow
with that pulse may be something that
kind of sticks through on the middle
there and create a bit of a better
transition there we go stuff like that
basically keep the entire part layout
fluid that said
dressing up the part is a huge part of
how your parts are going to look and
just to show it off a little bit to show
what you can kind of do with these
little in-between areas and with the
size of these parts one thing I very
often do with my past as well is
decorate them on the side with some
sidewalks now this is more of a Main
Street thing but since there are going
to be some buildings over here it could
be connected to some sort of Main Street
I still want to try something similar
here and the way I usually do this is
connect like entry points to the outside
curves because if you start doing it on
the inside curves you can't really keep
the part closest to the other part
pretty much on the outside that way you
can actually make sure that you stay
very close to that earlier part just
like this now as soon as you get to some
junctions you're going to have to turn
on angle snap that where you can
actually snap another Junction over here
there we go
now sometimes it doesn't quite want to
connect like over here the length of the
pot just isn't really working with the
boarder that I'm trying to maintain and
in cases like that you can kind of just
make off a new point where it splits off
and hopefully you can actually get a
decent curve from that that's not as bad
as it was so I'll take that and just go
through with the rest of it so now we
have the basic parts down and the last
work to be done it's pretty much to
detailing to bring it all together and
make it look clean pretty much so there
are a couple of things that I usually
want to do I want to make my custom
curbs putting some detailing and foliage
and maybe some port elements as well so
I'm going to start out with some of the
custom curbs to get rid of this ugly
border over here and also the lack of
curves over here so for this point I
usually just take any piece with the
texture I like like say for instance
this piece which is a pretty good top so
I'll take that and change the colors
very slightly to something brownish and
this is always the painstaking part this
is where you're pretty much just going
to have to follow the line of the path
here not much else to it and it also
just takes a bit of work to actually get
everything into place correctly but once
you're done doing that and you
the entire line you do have a very sick
custom curb which allows you to actually
cover up for those pretty weird
open areas between the in-game parts
there we go that's pretty much all for
that and you can do very similar things
for the curbs on the inside of the path
over here I sometimes use rocks as well
which work quite well and to save some
time what you can actually do on these
kinds of things is place whatever object
in the ground so that you're inside a
building place a few rocks and basically
then copy that building around so that
you can copy the same set of rocks
around to save you a little bit of time
on rock placement so here are my rock
building ready and all you have to do is
control X to copy it like this and
basically place it around to get lots of
rocks in a very small area in a very
small amount of time there we go our
little makeshift planter areas are
pretty much done and now it's time to
put some very simple foliage in there
now because I'm planning to build some
buildings over here and put it right
over here I don't want the foliage in
these planters to be too large really
just some decoration for the area and to
fill the space a bit so it doesn't seem
to empty out there but I also don't
really want to block any view so I'm
just going to go with some very small
trees and hopefully that should keep
things pretty much in place here so we
have one small tree here I'm just going
to place a couple smaller bushes around
this area and expert detailing and put
some of these very low bushes to get
some more texture to these planters as
well and see what else we can really add
without obstructing too much interview
do you kind of want to have something
that gives this already a bit more body
now for the buildings I'm just going to
get out some blueprints to give you a
very quick idea of how facades are going
to look at the side of this but I kind
of want to create a bit of a gallery
effect overhanging the sidewalk that I
have so far which is going to end up
looking pretty interesting and pretty
much just going to take all these assets
from Tennessee Valley and go up space
that way
all right there we go and you can
already kind of see it working like we
have the buildings curving we have these
facades kind of curving alongside
whatever landscape we're going to have
around here and we can really see the
plaza curving alongside that as well and
it's a lot less static than if these
buildings were just placed alongside one
simple path also this plaza kind of
gives you the space to look at these
buildings we have some interesting
foliage going on here as detailing but
it doesn't really block your view of the
buildings whereas if this which is one
simple path or something very straight
it would either not be as dynamic or of
the or as these buildings sorry or it
would just completely block the view of
these buildings are not really put a
spotlight on them as much is really
having a plaza in front of them does and
I'll just clean things up a little bit I
actually want to turn on the curb on the
ground path here just to get some extra
more detailing in this part on the side
here otherwise I would have to do that
coat myself and I'm not feeling like it
so yeah I'm just gonna turn them on
there and actually fix this a little bit
because that doesn't look too good more
trees around it to give you some more
context for how this kind of part would
look and obviously in this case it's
religious trees on the other side here
but in real life it could very well just
why am I saying in real life I can and
in your Park it could very well just be
more right over here or another section
of the park the point is that everything
connects pretty fluidly very smoothly
and the paths aren't very obviously
parts but they're more in a sense of a
theme park they're everywhere and you
can walk just about everywhere they kind
of flow everywhere except for those
areas where there are buildings or
planters or perhaps some rights if you
were to put a rind over here or some
more buildings over here you could very
well actually see this being a much more
enclosed kind of area with buildings
around all the sides of the plaza anyway
that is just about the point that I
wanted to bring over about that now if
it comes to pump detail but that's an
entirely different episode in itself you
definitely of course once the add some
lanterns along
side here as well some benches along the
pot to make everything come to life a
little bit more when it comes to these
buildings putting planters and small
trees and all kinds of details in front
of them will definitely make them come
to life a little bit more as well and in
turn I think those details make the
layout come to life a little bit more as
well but that's something that I can
much better show in an existing new Park
or I guess an existing theme park in
planet coaster so I'll show that off in
a little bit but this is to give you a
very broad idea of what this would look
like with all of the past details
installed so this is our small tranquil
part area and it's pretty much finished
state and if you can get a whole section
of the park
to look like this be it in your main
street or very important part of your
park or just something that's very
compact with lots of rights and
buildings around that's pretty much what
you're looking for now for an actual
example let's jump into quality all
right so we're in come on a beach for a
bit and personally this has always been
one of my favorite areas of the park
everything is closed at the moment for
mostly lag reasons which is also why
there aren't any guests in the park yet
even though they're currently still
coming in but anyway the frame rate is
pretty bad so I'm sorry about that but
this is one of my favorite areas because
it's it's all pretty much part but it
still happens to flow pretty smoothly
throughout the park as you can sell
those so this flowing and layouts of the
different parts going everywhere
but at the same time it's still quite
cozy it doesn't manage to become to open
by having all of these large planters in
the middle with all of this foliage and
a lot of this detailing alongside the
pots and you'll notice there are
different different ways over here of
filling up the open spaces between the
paths that you inevitably keep so for
instance over here I filled it up with
some sent and put some details in there
for these things there are some railings
along the sides with benches in the path
elements and threes in the middle and
then over here alongside the water
fronts we have these
key sort of elements which are in
between these parts where these parts
come together and actually these parks
or these parts come together pretty
awkwardly like they don't connect in
very good ways but all of the scenery
kind of covers up those issues and makes
it all look as if it is actually one
large sort of flowing part like that and
I guess a very similar thing goes over
here we're happy but stampeding to the
one light that's open but I filled in
the areas obviously very differently
here with different senses and less
detail since this needs to be quite open
for the diving coaster but it's still
that sort of general layouts that's true
and the last thing I wanted to show off
and this is not my idea I wish it was
but this has been interesting for quite
a while these things before aren't
exactly walking through them actually
have benches in the middle of them so
people can actually sit on the scenery
items I selected here there is a park
bench right underneath here and I think
that people just aren't tired enough yet
to actually sit on them but you can
actually have people sit on plant
elements like that just to think a very
quick thing that I just wanted to share
over although I think there should be
some pretty good examples of how you can
actually show in those spaces in between
your plants even if this is a bit of a
work in progress and in that way make
your plants flow a little bit more
smoothly alongside of course the general
layout of the paths in the first place
so thank you guys for watching this
tutorial I what I hope it sunny ways
thank you guys for watching this
tutorial I hope it was helpful in some
kind of way it's always been something
that I've been procrastinating on
because it's very difficult to make this
kind of tutorial there are all sorts of
things to be considered with parts and I
I still think it's one of the most
difficult things to get right in the
game
I still hope to focus on the smallest of
path details and really making them look
better on a very minor detail level kind
of tutorial later on and also I would
like to do a tutorial
on general park layout paths in the
future as well but for now this was
really just my like randomly put
together techniques which I normally use
in creating my paths especially from an
in-game standpoint of using these
shortcuts and the ways in which you can
manipulate the paths to be as smooth as
possible so yeah thanks again for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time